it's great to be joined today by dr.
Jamie Sampson who's an animal behavior
research scientist as well as the author
of the new book how to think like a
scientist it's so great to have you on
the program you know I couldn't help
notice that much of what you write about
and talk about in the book seems to have
overlap with some basic techniques of
epistemology critical thinking and sort
of challenging where our beliefs come
from am i right in my assessment that
thinking like a scientist includes many
of those skills yeah I think that's
correct scientific thinking is basically
just by an offshoot from critical
thinking the reason why text scientific
thinking is because it's more accessible
by people examples are more fun so they
they're more or less synonymous with
each other it's just a subset really why
would someone who isn't a scientist be
better off in day to day life if they
understand how scientists think and what
that means in other words give us some
examples of the ways in which day to day
one would benefit from a better
understanding of the scientific method
and so this book is really geared
towards understanding very scientific
components that you see within society
but as we touched upon at the start it
will also give you the tool but healthy
to think critically so to build logical
rational arguments I read the the
science is sort of a side argument the
reason why I use science because it's
prominent in society and at the moment
we are going through a turbine times of
science and so this book it doesn't only
help you way through the scientist in
society but really with big decisions so
such as the European referendum vote or
the recent American election it's it
really gives people with tools to think
think more critically using some fun
examples from science really
just aid in the learning in the second
part of the interview we're going to
dive into some more specific day-to-day
sort of in your everyday life examples
of when applying some of these concepts
would be useful but if we can start a
little more generally first Jamie what
are the types of mental mechanisms or
techniques or skills that you talked
about in the book that can be applied by
individuals when evaluating claims of
different kinds let's start sort of more
generally and then we'll get into
specifics in part two so one thing the
first thing is really just the determine
whether it's a trusted source and
Intimus a trusted source people really
should go do further acceleration of
course they're only sets a very
important topic it's about whether what
ice cream flavor you want is not really
applicable here but if if it's something
very important then you always look at
the source if it's a blog post or a
tabloid news media for example then you
want to go look further into it maybe if
it's a news article it has a link to a
study or a link to an opinion poll so
the first things really do is just to
look at the quality of information and
then see whether you can you can take it
further and then really the next step is
then just to follow the full of the
breadcrumbs and see see where it leads
you along the way the most important
thing is obviously to have a very open
mind about opinions and beliefs so don't
go into an argument or don't really
build up a belief about something
without really researching it first so
go open mind and try and look at all
viewpoints so don't just look at the
points that performed what you want to
believe to some degree theory to some
degree it's good to also be able to
balance or to avoid I guess false
balance or false neutrality as well
right I mean when when I think of
the issue that comes to my mind is that
of climate change in climate science
because often you will hear from
so-called climate science skeptics hey
we want both sides of the story told and
sometimes this can lead to a lack of
objectivity and a false neutrality where
you might give climate skeptics who
represent a tiny fraction of the
scientific community the same amount of
time or consideration as what is the
scientific consensus so can you address
how to both have an open mind and listen
to different points of view but at the
same time not fall into this downward
spiral of false neutrality it's look I
think there are examples where obviously
it is there is for one size argument
such as such as climate change and if
you approach climate change from the
other way if your fault denial and you
start looking at blogs on climate change
denial you run the risk of confirming
your own belief so you you manifest
confirmation bias right and so if you
approach that legend one again well what
are the arguments for human there
climate change so I think if you go into
the argument with a more environment you
may change your belief but it's also if
you are Pro climate change it's also
understanding what the other side argues
that you've got good council arguments
because if you have no idea why someone
is a climate change denier then you're
not really going to be prepared to
counter their ideas with investigate
logical arguments as to why climate
change is real to stick with the climate
change example just for a second an
argument I don't know that I even want
to call it an argument an assertion that
some climate science deniers sometimes
make is it doesn't matter whether ninety
seven percent or ninety nine percent or
whatever percentage of climate
scientists believe that humans are
impacting our climate scientists have
been wrong in the past what do people
who make that claim fundamentally
misunder
stand about the scientific method as it
exists today and I think they just fill
the scientists attic so once you have an
answer that's it it will never ever
change unless we know from science
things change all the time and science
is always progressing if we take
evolution for example and look at what
Darwin wrote about evolution since the
origins of published it's gone through a
drastic change and it's always it's
always changing where new evidence
appears and so with climate change and
with the solutions overall or
understanding it will never change some
of the parts will some small proponents
will as we developed a more
sophisticated techniques to for example
measure ocean temperatures except them
we will find there will be tweaks in the
idea but the overall theme will never
change because we have so much evidence
to back up our arguments is there some
way in which we can quantify or even
qualify the differences in why
scientific consensus today is stronger
than what would be considered scientific
consensus 300 years ago in other words
can we point to technology can we point
to what what what can we point to to say
you can't point to a scientific
misunderstanding of 300 years ago to
imply the same likelihood of one today I
mean I think it's the whole is that the
four of things so you mentioned
technology so technology is is one of
the things again the climate science you
have more accurate predictions or if we
go to my field with animal behavior we
have things such as a hiking technology
so we take animals we can get really
accurate daily Diaries what they do so
these tools weren't available and we
also have more scientists working on
some of the smaller questions so we have
the Einsteins and the Newton's Darwin's
working on
idea but so science has really really
developed over the last centuries so now
we have scientists working on very very
small ideas and these always out of the
field before we jump into some specific
examples that might might relate to
people's day to day you talked about in
your reddit AMA about the issue of
scientists corrupted by or influenced by
corporations or the way that their work
is funded and I think that this will be
instantly analogous to many in our
audience to the way in which news
outlets can be influenced by their
advertisers how big of an issue is this
in science because I've spoken to people
who say it's a big issue and I've spoken
to others who say you know regardless of
who's funding a study the individual
scientist is going to do the work the
way they see they see fit and that they
believe is best is there a strong
feeling on that one way or the other
from your point of view I think it
really depends on what class it is so in
my field there isn't though there is no
way that you can really influence by by
corporate corporate needs or be
corrupted by some ideas but there are
some science science areas where there
is potential although I haven't really
studied at all when we looked at much
evidence that some biomedical science
you have funded by a say a big a big
organization they might pressure you to
maybe publish certain results but I
think for the most part all scientists
want to do we just thought again just
follow the evidence and we just
published what we see in front of us I
think with a lot with every profession
there is some you do get some cases of
fraud but I think again sighs because we
are oversight such as peer review this
fraud is is really reduced we've been
speaking with dr. Jamie Sampson the book
is how to think like a scientist we will
pick it up tomorrow and talk about some
day-to-day ways in which applying this
type of critical thinking can be useful
to you we're continuing our conversation
with dr. Jamie Sampson who's an animal
behavior research scientist as well as
the author of the new book how to think
like a scientist in part one of the
interview we talked more generally about
the scientific method corruption by
money the corporate influence etc I'd
like to now dig into some of the sort of
day-to-day decisions that the average
non scientists who listens to our
conversation or read your book might
apply some of the techniques and
knowledge that you talk about critical
thinking basic epistemology scientific
method etc to make better decisions in
their day-to-day life so I'm open to
sort of diving in wherever you want to
let's just pick one example that you
think is illustrative of the type of
thought that you're encouraging the
average person to engage in day to day
so I think one example which we have
seen recently was with the European
referendum about whether so there's
decision for Britain to leave or remain
in the EU and if you look at various
polls if you look at longer studies they
showed that people have a lack of
understanding and this is on both sides
of the argument for why we should remain
or why we should leave the EU and so I
think if people were able to adopt some
of the skills I show in the book people
would have had a lot a more logical
argument for why they're voting either
either way so I think that it's really
the impulsive decisions such as that
where these critical skills are most
important is this more broadly sort of
in the in the world of media literacy
whether it's the reading of poll numbers
or particularly I think a really
prominent issue is when there's a
scientific study that's done and then
there will be articles written in
popular media about it we're very often
the head
lines are drastically either
exaggerating or even miss stating what
the actual results of the scientific
study say so does this come down to
being able to sort of go beyond
headlines and be able to interpret
source material yes so I I use that
example in the book where there's a
chance to where you can or I'll try and
teach you how to really put apart junk
science in the media from the media's
perspective you can understand why they
have these these headline-grabbing
articles because it really sells more
more papers but what it does is it's
either promotion junk science which the
scientists didn't intend to do or it
just promotes the idea that scientists
are doing silly things so is good for
you chocolate can help you use weight
and if people don't have an
understanding of the science they look
at that and say well what these
scientists doing messing around there
and chocolate when they should be doing
that curing cancer but then if you go
back to the studies themselves they
don't really say much about they're all
chocolate so it's it's really helpful to
tease apart some of these big obstacles
find the source material and get your
teeth into them and what are some of the
primary ways that when you see a
headline about you know promising new
cancer treatment offers best alternative
yet for treating a particular condition
and then when you go and you look at the
data often the data doesn't seem to
match up with the headline what are some
specific pieces of information that
people can look for is it comparison to
placebos is it sample size what advice
can you give people for interpreting
some of these junk science articles that
are written so it's quite complex so I
think that's the first thing to do is
what I mentioned yesterday which is look
at the source so in most studies even is
bear the very junk they will have
so and so scientists from so-and-so
Institute says this in latest study if
you then Google for that researcher are
the Institute's and maybe roughly what
the studies about you'll probably find a
link to the article itself or you'll
find a link to the press release which
has been written by the by the author or
one on co-authors of the study and then
you can go and compare what was in the
study or press release to what was in
the news article I think for most lay
people reading the scientific study is
is a waste of time because it's very
difficult and long class to get into
them even studies outside of my field I
find quite difficult to read but the the
press releases are which are written in
such a way that anyone can understand
and if you scan through the press
release you can find various ideas for
the articles about a match it to the to
the news article and the next thing you
can do is if it's something that you're
really concerned about is look at the
integrity of where the study was
published so if it was published in a
leading journals and putting more
accurate with something that was
published in a newsletter a lot Peer
Review Journal and are there particular
areas of science reporting that you
think are particularly prone to these
sort of hyperbolic headlines whether
it's you know the health effects of a
particular food be they positive or
negative the prospects of treatments for
certain conditions and the way in what
areas should people be particularly
cautious so I would say in health
sciences biomedical sciences are really
the main area where junk science can
really influence our life because if you
drastically change your diet based on a
tabloid media drunk article it could
really have a
your health and so people should really
be be aware of these studies and people
should also understand that a lot of
these studies are small-scale studies so
it might focus on a particular gene in
like the study might involve mice rather
than humans and so to draw these huge
conclusions can potentially be dangerous
especially that the news article start
stressing things such as this is the
cure for cancer when quite clearly it
isn't speaking more broadly now to guard
against personal bias
this can include confirmation bias this
can include source bias personal biases
of different kinds what are the best
ways for an individual to sort of guard
against the personal biases they may
bring to their interpretation of a
particular issue so you can't really
overcome biases because they manifest
themselves all the time or you can do is
if you if you're aware of them then you
can realize when they're they're
starting to manifest so if people
understand what the type of biases are
then they can overcome so for example
confirmation bias don't go into into
researching a topic if you already have
a predetermined idea of what you want to
want to find out so for example if I
believe that vaccines cause autism which
I don't but if I if I did and I went
online licensed vaccines cause autism
well I could what I would probably find
is I would find loads of junk science
websites which reports
thank you complicated language about
linking vaccines autism and that will
confirm my bias so people really should
go into that with a watered down opinion
or really just an unbiased opinion and
then they can look at information from
both sides of the argument rather than
immediately looking a pinion because
some fuel ideas practically speaking
though that can be tough to do right
because I mean most people will use the
internet to start looking into this if
you google vaccines cause autism or do
vaccines cause autism question mark
you're going to still get a lot of
similar results right so what what I
mean I guess you'd have to proactively
search for papers saying both that they
do in don't I I don't know I mean it's
very tough well it's more again if you
if you look at the search time for
example so if you do back-to-school
water or autism question mark then
you've probably be met with the CDC
website sensitive Disease Control and
World Health Organization website but if
you enter loaded terms into Google so
vaccines cause autism then you will you
won't be linked or you might not be
linked back to the CDC or World Health
Organization website you might get
linked back to Sidda scientific or junk
science log on vaccines and autism well
this says hard to imagine a time where
this has been more important
particularly in the time of propaganda
news we've been speaking with the author
of the book how to think like a
scientist dr. Jamie Sampson thanks so
much for talking to us about this thanks
very much